I'll have a story do it the laughter
will tell on this podcast before I met
you kalila yeah I was rolling up at the
college store on a Monday night and it
parked my car and there was a girl just
wandering around the parking lot she
comes up to me she's very cute she goes
hi I think you're so funny
yep I know she is yeah and I go oh oh
yeah she goes she's [ __ ] everybody let
me tell the story she goes yeah I think
you're really funny think you're so
talented I can't believe I'm meeting you
I go oh cool she's like I live in
Bakersfield I drove down here I don't
want to go drive back and I just stay at
your house I'm like thank you Jesus yeah
this is the Lord at work she's pretty
hot every booth yeah yeah so she comes
to my house a house right uh-huh and we
make love I don't even know her name
but you know it's like lottery know
nothing to be cam yeah yeah and so she
stays at my house for a week like she
does have a job or anything like what
the [ __ ] so Saturday night I'm at a
restaurant I can't tell you who the
names but a comedian calls me and says
yo that girl you're with don't bring her
to the comedy storm with my girlfriend I
go yeah but why can't I bring her oh
we've all had her and he listened a
twenty name oh my god comics I know
that's been with her that's different
though she's a thot yeah that's just the
thought she's a god when I do you so
much right now
so what's the first one those are two
years old what's the first one ha ha ha
15 years ago the top right and she's a
she's a thot they all tend to rhyme what
does that mean
it's that hole
over there right she's a thot good type
that a came up with that that's a genius
one fun but like it's not like I was a
legit still a word
what about tubular okay
she's a thottie it all the comedian's
had like great relationships that were
very long then they went to Joshua Tree
together yeah
but they probably just like smashed and
I was it hey baby I'm gonna smash your
[ __ ] vagina in Hawaii when we go next
week yeah X is completely yes they offer
they're all yeah yeah yeah and I yeah
what do you think Bobby would you date
somebody that okay let's say a friend of
mine like a distant friend of mine would
you date her if anything happened
between you and I know why not a distant
friend no because I if because the I
think now because this is the longest
girlfriend ever had and I think and I
know that what she's and I love her the
most yeah but if anyone I've ever met
yeah so I don't think that I could
because I think the only way this is
gonna end is if she leaves know shut the
so when she leaves me I wouldn't be able
to like I don't want anything to remind
me of her and so no I wouldn't do it
okay so yeah guys meeting I think you
should have talked with your friend and
say hey do it I'm not okay with you Jake
you don't appreciate what I just said
this [ __ ] right here does the lyrics
and my heart will go on
maybe you're a thought yeah can you dad
for my things yeah yeah I'll tap right
now guys we're doing a live dab is it a
video Bobby show me how you dab I'll
chew how that was pretty [ __ ] who
made up that DAP yeah it's like a dance
craze move that's all well it's
confusing because dabs came out around
this baby what's that one that's where
the oils that you smell I thought it was
spelling right same thing it's not
synonymous but it's the same what do you
call it when they're spelled the same
but they're not don't look at me
whatever the thing they do they tickler
yeah is that real
yeah that's Sora's in sarod abuja Oh
Sarah the booth I'll see the video I
give Aquafina round of applause
everybody
[Music]
four days
[Music]